first
latinos against liberalism that's the
focus of tonight's angle
now it seems like just yesterday when
the conventional wisdom repeated
endlessly on the airwaves
was that trump-era republicans kind of
risked losing hispanic voters forever
and even having this conversation sends
a powerful signal they're doing high
fives in the clinton campaign right now
when they hear this the things he is
saying that is turning off
are turning off large blocks of voters
hispanic voters nobody in the republican
party knows what donald trump's
immigration policy is other than that
it's hardline which turns off hispanic
voters hispanics have been trending
republican for years what has turned
them around has been this hard line
immigration
now indeed democrats thought they had
the latino vote in the bag forever just
throw them a few cliches about how we're
a nation of immigrants and then humor
them with meaningless gestures or as
it's now called his spandering
late padillo sartoris los muertos que se
mentagan infamous infamous uh sobre el
huracan sandy yamando
it's great to be back with all of you
dios de bandiga
that's about as good as i get
well it was right about that that is
about as good as it gets with them
empty rhetoric in bad spanish
now more latinos are onto the democrats
game today although biden did win 61
percent of their vote last go-round
donald trump actually grew his support
by eight percentage points nationwide
among latinos and as vox noted last year
in many of the districts that flipped
from dem to republican in 2020 latinos
were at least 17 percent of the
electorate it turns out that hispanic
voters they don't really care if you
speak spanish they care about results
and biden and the democrats in congress
they're obviously not delivering results
among latinos the president's approval
ratings now stands at a stunningly low
26 percent
if you're nancy pelosi there's not
enough designer ice cream in the freezer
to make that go down any better
the issues that latinos care about are
also the issues that the rest of us care
about
inflation is the top concern with jobs
in the economy coming in second
and guess who they think is better on
the economy and inflation duh
well according to an ipso survey among
latinos republicans edge out democrats
24 to 19. and notable is that back in
december there was no difference between
the two parties
so things have only deteriorated in
these past three months we see that
leading more hispanics to ask important
questions like
is my paycheck actually keeping up with
the increased cost of living or can my
kids get a good education or are things
better or worse than they were let's say
in 2019
or do i have the money to fill my tank
this week and where am i going to get my
next can of baby formula
they don't seem to like the answers
they're hearing on any of those
questions we know about federal efforts
to improve the the stock rates
nationwide have these shipments from
other countries made a dent
so that's the thing instead of getting
better it's slightly worse during the
week of may 22nd about 74 percent of
formula was out of stock
wow
and the tweets they're not working
either biden says his plan to tackle
inflation that latinos care so much
about it's a simple plan
let the fed do its job
lower costs and keep reducing the
deficit
i kid you not you cannot make this up
they have to know that none of this is
going to work i don't think they believe
it
so now they hope that exploiting tragedy
is going to work and doing spanish
language ads for gun control
dios mios muy stupido
so how can the democrats be so ignorant
and so smug at the same time
they literally cannot fathom that latino
voters actually think for themselves the
daughter of well-known liberal jorge
ramos her name is paola did an entire
show on the topic for msnbc she seemed
shocked by what hispanic voters told her
on a wide range of issues including why
they switch from dem to republican
one of the things that we found
throughout the entire trip is that
almost every single person that we
talked to every single one of them was a
former democrat believe that they had to
be
a democrat at least the heart of what is
driving many of these latino voters this
disenchantment with the democratic party
and yes i think these culture wars and
what you're seeing now is sort of
uncovering these very innate
social conservative values that many
latinos do have and maybe now with trump
they feel okay saying that with pride
well the interviews she did were
actually really revealing it turns out
that latinos want schools that teach not
ones that indoctrinate
i have six kids in total the two little
ones are currently homeschooling i
pulled them out of school 2020.
when why
there was a lot going on but 2020 for me
was uh
what i like to call my political
awakening
i have never been politically inclined
ever
my father was so i grew up
hearing about
a lot to do with politics
a possible communist takeover and all
this craziness but in my mind i always
thought
this is just my dad and his trauma you
know from being a political prisoner
so i always shied away from that i
actually resented it
but i feel that 2020 there was no
denying what was going on and for me it
hit most with the children what are they
learning here that they're not learning
in school
for me it's safety so i know that they
are not going to learn
a certain positions like what
uh for example i don't have anything
against the lgbtq community at all
i don't think the kids should have it
pushed on them
i love that ominous music that played
under that clip for a while but it's
just kind of common sense latinos don't
want their kids groomed in the classroom
shocking
well at least it was to the former rnc
chief turned poser for a paycheck
michael steele
i mean
are
you know have they always been anti-lgbt
ltgb
q or are they you know suddenly
discovering that the talking point again
was we are doing this because we want to
protect the children
oh how could you dare protect the
children
because democrats don't see the freight
train coming down the track with
hard-working god-fearing hispanic voters
riding in it
if they don't see that then they're
going to get wiped out by the group that
they
wanted to simply throw together with
other minority voters take them for
granted
by this bright lights pelosi and schumer
should have paid attention to what
happened in virginia last november
in jason miaris they elected the state's
first hispanic attorney general
but while the swamp remained tone deaf
and stuck in their old paradigms miara's
focused on common sense and crime
but instead of giving latinos pragmatic
solutions to the problems plaguing their
communities democrats gave them a new
nickname
latinx students are more likely to
borrow money to go to college it's awful
hard as well
to get
latinx vaccinated as well i've had the
chance to meet with latinx leaders and
no matter where i connect with latinx
communities one thing is certain latinx
families are feeling squeezed to the
breaking point
it turns out that actual latino voters
hate the term according to a new survey
by echelon insights
how embarrassing
the republicans message to latino voters
here should be pretty straightforward
and clear
if you want a better life for your
children a chance for a thriving
business safer streets
real respect for your faith and values
and schools that teach without
propaganda then say goodbye to the
democrat party
if you want a future though for your
kids that leaves them with no real
options other than maybe pot porn and
government checks then stay with biden's
crew absolutely
the truth is the liberals don't really
like you
they just use you and they talk down to
you every single campaign season
they think you're stupid we think you're
smart
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else